Hôm nay, người quét xuống 5.5 của chính phủ,
có hiểu lực từ ngày 19, năm 2019,
giá Sang Giàu trong nước sẽ được điều trình ngày sau một ngày,
nếu giá cơ sở của một trong các mặt hàng phù biến tăng từ 15,000 trở lên,
so với ki điều hành trước.
Ở chung ngược lại, khi giá cơ sở giáng từ 15,000 trở lên,
giá Sang Giàu cũng sẽ được điều trình ngày sau đó một ngày.
Trong trình hợp, mức đến đồng thấp hơn các ngựt này,
việc điều hành giá vẫn thực hiện định kỳ vào thứ 15 hành gần theo quy định hiện hàng.
Sò với chức đây, nước điều trình kỳ giá tăng đã được năng từ 20,000 lệ 1,000,
có phần hạn chế biến đồng ngắn hàng.
Ngị quét thuộc xàu bộ công tyng chủ trì,
phố hợp với bộ tại chính trong việc sách liện và công bố xá Sang Giàu.